hey guys this is andrew for
chosencensus.com so for those who don't
know me yet let me quickly introduce
myself i've been working as a
professional trainer for the past six
years in hong kong
and right now i'm doing youtube videos
where i want to show you guys how to use
technical analysis
to set up the trades and build up your
different scenarios
so in this video i want to make an
update on amc and show you how to use
divergences
moving averages and macd to actually
choose
between the different scenarios that you
have built using illiad wave principles
let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys i've published i think in
the same time
a video where i show you the different
scenarios that i build up using illiot
wave principle
so i'm not gonna do this again here go
watch this video so you can see the two
or three different scenarios that i have
and
in this video i want to show you how to
actually pick up
the most likely scenario that we're
gonna call our preferred scenario
very quickly my different scenarios were
either w x y which is abc
abc abc that is finished here and then
we are doing a one two three four five
that is one scenario the second scenario
is that actually the
wxy is going lower to 750 and then we're
gonna have
this same one two three four five but
starting here
so to choose between the shortened berry
scenario and
short-term bullish scenario because in
the long term this is bullish anyway
uh we are gonna use first the moving
averages very quickly just for those who
want to know more about idiot worth
principle just
click on the link in the description of
the video and you're gonna receive a
free
video where i explain everything about
this theory
now i go back to the moving averages
which i really like to use so once again
the first thing you need to do guys
like i always say you go from one time
frame to the other one and
you see what is working the best so for
example on the forest time frame
that is the best time frame for me to
use you know every trader
would tell you different things but you
know from my experience
and like i said i've been doing this for
quite a long time i
see the best reactions on the four west
time frame and the 200 period moving
average is for me
the golden one is the one you know
that's why i put it in yellow it's the
one that i think
is the most important one and here guys
let's do it together what do you see
if you analyze a chart and you see this
what can you tell
all right simple you can see that the
100
moving average is acting perfectly guys
as support
in the most recent past once again guys
we are trying to analyze what is
happening here
and to do that we actually check if
there were nice reactions in the
past like if i go really back in time i
don't see any
very nice reactions but it's enough for
me to see that i have
those one two three four five reactions
on
uh the four hours time frame in the very
recent past
and we are trading above we are also
trading above the 20 period moving
average
but you can see that the signals are a
bit messy you know so it's
almost like you don't need this one but
maybe one then you would need it so
always keep this
on your charts then you change the time
frame you go on a daily
and on the daily time frame guys what do
we see
same thing with 100 moving average is
very far away
so it's not going to bring us any
indication here
but we're having the 50 period moving
average that is acting as
support a bit the same way so basically
it's like the same information that we
already had on the forward time frame
so once again that's why the first time
frame is the best as you could see the
reactions were cleaner
and we're having you know shorter
candles so it's better
to like you know identify a breakout
because it goes faster
so moving averages are just telling us
guys we are bullish because we're
training above so this is not enough
to conclude this is one information
second information i want to show you
guys
is divergences so i've shown you guys
this before
in my videos so very quickly you have
two types of divergence you have the
regular divergence and the hidden
divergence so the regular divergence
price action in blue indicator in red
alright so i use the macd you can use
rsi or stochastic
so a regular divergence is let's do the
bullish case when the price action is
going lower
but the momentum indicator is going
higher which is showing that the market
is out of steam that the burst are
losing control
because the momentum is shifting
direction the momentum is going higher
regular divergence the one i showed you
guys
last week was a hidden divergence is the
market is making higher lows
all right from here to here the market
is going higher but
the indicator is going lower what does
it mean it means
that there is a very strong bearish
momentum as you can see
with the magnet that is you know
drifting lower
but somehow the price action is going
higher so
the bulls were strong enough to actually
hold
the price above this first low
and to make higher low so this is a
hidden divergence let's go back to the
chart
right now let me show you very quickly
the hidden divergence that i showed you
guys already
on the daily time frame market making
higher lows from here
to here what is the macd doing the macd
is going lower from here to here all
right from 0.2 to minus 0.2
so this is a hidden divergence so on a
daily time frame it all depends on which
time frame you're looking for
we are bullish so it means that probably
we're gonna make a new high and then
we're gonna make
a higher low again you know we are in
this type of
uh situation so this is basically
something that i knew already is that
we're gonna have a one two and then a
three
right this is the only information that
it's giving me so it's information i had
already
but it's confirming that my one two is
gonna be followed probably by a three
then we go on a shorter time frame
because
the answer we are looking for is on the
shorter term
we know we are bullish on the long term
what we don't know is if we are going to
750 before bouncing back
so to do that you need to look for and
to find
divergences if there are some on the
shorter term let's do it together guys
we are looking for a market that is out
of steam
for a market that is reverting so where
is the bearish trend
the bearish trend is here guys all right
so let me get rid of those
all right you can see that we're going
lower and you can see guys that
my signals are actually kind of
early signals because i showed you guys
this trend line that
broken on the 15th of april right so on
the 15th of april
okay we wait for a second signal at 12
a.m
i was turning bullish on the short term
so this is you know of course
one more reason that i think you know
we're probably gonna make
one two three right away and that we
won't be going to 750 but i need to
consider every uh
cases to be professional so here
the price action is going lower i'm
showing you guys how to find divergences
so let's connect the lows and then we
check the macd
24-25 so it's here
13th of april oh hmm
interesting what do we have guys
we are having a regular divergence the
price action
is making lower lows so it's
bearish but the momentum indicator
given here by the macd is actually going
higher
so this is a regular divergence that we
found
on the short term on the four hours time
frame
so i have one long-term divergence
hidden divergence and one
short-term regular divergence let's see
on the one-hour time frame i haven't
done this yet
if we get anything from the price action
here
so very quickly i see that we have
nothing
because higher lows
and higher lows as well so no divergence
logo highs lower macd
so no divergence which doesn't mean
that we won't shift momentum but we
don't see this indication so what is the
very shortened
momentum guys just look at the macd all
right the macd
is green the signal is green and the
macd is mostly trading in positive
territory so on the hourly timeframe
for now we are bullish and we don't have
any divergence
so we don't have any sign of momentum
shift
so all this information for now are
going into
the same direction is that we won't be
going to 750
we will do the third wave right now very
soon
so one more thing i want to show you and
then i'm done
is the macd itself let me remind you
guys what is the macd
uh so the macd is the difference between
two exponential moving averages
the 12th day the period it can be day
four hours whatever 12th period
exponential moving average minus
the 26 period exponential moving average
so this is the macd
so it's a difference of exponential
moving averages and
the magnitude then you smooth it using
the 9 day exponential moving average of
the mighty itself
so then you obtain the orange line that
is here and then you compute the
difference of those two and this is
giving you the macd
signal and look guys what is the macd
signal
for now so the signal is given by a
change of sign
you know when it's green and it goes to
red
so for example we had like the signal
here right
so here the macd signal turned red and
told you guys that we are bearish
all right what i'm interested in is when
is the
macd gonna turn green because i can tell
you guys that there are a lot of
big money investors like asset managers
or institutional clients that are using
the magazine just
blindly on the daily time frame they use
it on the daily time frame i know about
it i have some friends that work in this
kind of companies
and they're telling me that they keep an
eye on the magazine of course they're
not only using this those guys are using
a lot of fundamental analysis
but on top of the fundamental analysis
when they want to find an
entry point you know when for example
they want to buy amc
but they don't know when they're gonna
just
wait for the macd to turn green and the
day it's turning green
they're gonna buy i'm gonna show you
guys for example here
what happened so 23rd of feb
would turn green so here and then right
away guys the next day we're having a
very
strong move up then it got rejected fair
enough
but then we kept moving higher and
this last for you know around two three
weeks
so this is the usual period of time for
amc
the cycle we're having right now it can
be you know two months
it can be anything but right now what
we're having on amc
is around three weeks and guys we are
almost complete here
if i consider this cycle would last the
same period of time than
the cycle before we are almost done
and if the price action just remains
around this level
you know so it could get strongly sold
tomorrow
then the macd would you know keep
turning
red it's possible all right this is
possible but if we just
remain around this level or make a new
high
then the macd is going to turn green and
we're going to have this massive buying
liquidity that is coming in in the game
and that is going to help us push the
price action higher
and once again guys let me remind you
what i told you
when i did my different cases guys i was
telling you that
here if we go above 1120
we cannot have an abc like this because
the b
wave cannot go above the beginning of
the a wave
and if we actually go closer to this 11
20 guys the macd is going to turn green
so you know this is gonna
the kind of association that you guys
can make you know you can suppose that
if the price action comes close to the
11
area the macd is gonna turn green and
we're gonna have of course
this kind of rejection as we always do
when we close to some
resistance levels but probably gonna
blow it
right away and we are gonna do this
third wave that
i'm expecting coming very
soon so guys that's it for me i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to shore i see you guys